We turn now to the key part of
the analysis where we show that
each phase of the Dinic
algorithm takes V times E time.
As with Edmonds-Karp,
we will use a level graph.
In this case, however,
the algorithm actually builds the graph,
whereas in Edmonds-Karp we
simply used it for the analysis.
The level graph can be built
by running Bedford search and
saving all forward edges while
ignoring backwards and lateral ones.
As we argued before,
when we augment the flow along the path,
say along this one here, we introduce
reverse edges into the residual graph.
Note that these are always
backwards edges in the level graph.
And hence they aren't useful
in building a path equal to or
shorter than the previous shortest path.
Well if the new edges are useless,
why rebuild the level graph
of the residual graph when the old
one will serve just as well?
We can just update
the residual capacities.
More precisely,
given the possibly outdated level graph,
we can build a path from source to
sync just by making the first vertex
on the adjacency list
the next vertex in the path.
If this generates a path to t,
then we augment the flow and
update the residual capacities.
If it doesn't, then we delete the last
vertex in the path from the level graph.
In this example, we would,
first find a path from s to t, and,
let's say that this edge
here is a bottle neck.
It's capacity gets set to 0,
and it gets deleted.
Next, we will build a path from s again,
and
this time, we would run into a dead end.
So we delete this vertex, and, continue.
There are only V vertices in the graph.
So we can't run into more than V
dead ends, and every augmentation
deletes the bottleneck edge, so
we can't delete more than E edges.
Overall then,
we won't try more than E path.
This process however, of building
the path by first in the adjacency list,
and then augmenting or
deleting a vertex as appropriate.
Each time that set of operations is
done, only costs us order V time.
So, overall, then,
we're doing order V work, order E times.
So, overall,
this work takes order V times E.
Taking this all together,
then, we have V phases.
And each one of the individual phases
costs order E times V time, for a total
of E times V squared time overall, which
is an improvement over Edmonds-Karp.